en 1943 en pleine occupation ya un film
qui est sorti qui a eu un succès
phénoménal s'appelait l'éternel retour
basé sur le mythe de tristan et iseult
saint film de jean delannoy avec
madeleine sologne est l'acteur principal
avait déjà connu la gloire cinq ans plus
tôt avec les parents terribles de
cocteau sur scène mais là ça a été un
engouement exceptionnel enfin la
meilleure preuve c'est que son pull le
pull jacquard qu'il portait par le fils
a eu autant de succès a été autant à la
mode que quelques années plus tard le
blouson noir de johnny hallyday ou la
frange des beatles
ensuite il a été l'acteur fétiche de
cocteau pour ses plus grands films hors
fait la belle et la bête le testament
d'orphée avant d'en chanter une autre
génération avec des films comme le bossu
la princesse de clèves ou fantômas
aujourd'hui à 70 ans il revient c'est
l'éternel retour qui continue voici jean
marais
bienvenue sur le plateau de scoop à la
une
merci qui merci d'être là merci à vous
aussi alors jean marc est justement
quand j'ai dit à ma mère que je vous
avais invité à scoop à la une
elle m'a dit par lui du pull-over parce
que c'est un truc ça a été vraiment une
mode fun non ce pull overs à sochaux le
vert il faut dire que je savais que
j'allais tourner ce film depuis très
longtemps
jean cocteau avec les scénarios furieux
que des propositions qu'on me faisait
aussi débat me disant que je devais
jouer les héros qu' il y avait que deux
grandes histoires d'amour depuis que la
littérature existait c'était c'était
roméo et juliette et tristan et zulte et
il a écrit une version moderne de
tristan et zulte et puis je suis parti
en italie tournée carmen et dans une
vitrine un jour je me promenais j'ai vu
ce pour le verre et je me suis dit ce
serait très bien beau ce film et je les
ai achetés et tout le monde voulait le
même ça a été la marque au pied levé et
on maîtrisait pour me demander les
points du polo vert ça voulait dire les
points des poules devait alors vous êtes
mais quand même enfin avant la guerre de
14 g né le 11 12 13 le 11 décembre 1913
vous avez été un témoin de l'histoire
privilégiez vous avez été aux premières
loges pendant de longues années
est-ce que vous lui posez une question
toute simple est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que les choses vont de mieux
en mieux ou plus en plus mal sur terre
donges a toujours été mal ça faisait
plus mal ça va pas mieux
non non ça va mieux alors vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui toutes les toutes les
stars se battent pour des pour des
grandes causes et c'est pas c'est pas
mal d'ailleurs mais enfin il ya vraiment
un engouement de toutes les facettes
très silencieux tout sympathique mais si
cocteau était là à votre avis qu'est-ce
qu'il ferait ce qu'ils se battraient
pour des grandes causes comme ça il
s'est toujours battu pour des grandes
causes oui ça lui a d'ailleurs fait
beaucoup d'ennuis facile à 6 et beaucoup
de de manifeste pour des contres les
condamnations à mort comme rnp ar oui
les gens comme ça et j'ai continué le
immédiatement on donner une étiquette
politique qu'il n'avait pas car il est
dit je suis comme il était c'est à dire
que on est en dehors de tout parti oui
alors il ya quand même je suis pas la
première fois que je vous ai vu s'il ya
une semaine je crois vous aviez joué en
matinée le samedi en soirée le samedi en
matinée le dimanche en soirée le
dimanche
vous êtes arrivé au bar vous avez
commandé une joie de jouer assez bas
c'est un peu fatiguant quand même vous
êtes arrivé non c'est une vodka tonic et
vous aviez une forme extraordinaire vous
m'avez dit que la rive gauche à 4 heures
du matin oui alors votre secret c'est
quoi pour voir j'ai pas de secret si je
le disais ce serait plus à ce très mad
accord gêné et ce n'est pas en profiter
je n'ai jamais eu le secret j'ai j'ai
une chance insolente d'avoir une bonne
santé
oui voilà mais pas d'autre secret non
merci